my name is villa tulas i used to work at
netflix before founding this company
called outer bounds and like yeah i mean
as as david mentioned like back at
netflix we started developing this
framework called metaflow it's open
source at metaflow.org so if you don't
want to listen to any of this i mean you
can just like check out the webpage and
it has plenty of information
and um
now yeah indeed about a year ago i left
to kind of a startup company around this
and and like both at netflix as well as
of course at the new company like we
have been thinking about this big
question that like what is what is
exactly the modern stack for ml
infrastructure
and uh it's kind of interesting that
like bake into that phrase the modern
stack there's a bit of an assumption
that there was something before and
maybe there will be something after
maybe a postmodern stack for ml or
something something of that sort
and uh and like even even more so i mean
the interesting question that there's
the baked in assumption that um
that there is some kind of a stack in
the first place and like for those of
you those of you who have been following
this like a sprawling space of ml ops
over the past few years there's a lot of
confusion a lot of fragmentation that do
we even have a stack i mean like is
there a stack that we can use to build
machine learning applications are there
multiple different stacks for different
use cases or could it be even so that
there is one the stack that everybody
should be using at least conceptually
due to build
these applications powered powered by
machine learning that that deliver lots
of business value
and uh and it is it is a confusing space
indeed and uh whenever like i find
myself in in a confusing situation that
there are like kind of so much going on
that it's hard to figure out what even
makes sense and what doesn't i
oftentimes look back in history and and
try to think that okay anything has
anything like this happened in the past
and of course like pretty much always
like when it comes to tech like we we
realized that we just keep reinventing
the same things over and over again and
i think like when it comes to the
question of the stack like one of the
interesting comparison points at least
to me um is is that that of the web
stack so you know like if you want to
build an e-commerce store and like
imagine like if you wanted to build an
e-commerce store back in like during the
dot-com boom i mean like maybe 98 or 99
or so um there used to be this stack
it's really called the stack and like it
was lamp uh and it consisted of of linux
as as the operating system apache web
server as your web server mysql database
and then like people were really excited
about the php the language back in the
day
and that was really the stack how people
built applications back then and if you
actually like peak under the hood like
what building an application like with
the lamp stack looked like back in the
day um you you had a diagram like this i
mean this is actually like from the
wikipedia page like for the lamp stack
and i guess the kind of what i want you
to pay attention here especially
is that like you have this like things
in the middle like the storage layer
like there are
things like uh sata sas scsi and so
forth i don't know how many of you even
like know what these terms mean because
they don't like seem to make any
difference these days anymore and it's
actually fascinating that they also
highlighted
different file systems like x4 there's
the process scheduler like you had the
device driver for the network interface
card and stuff like that and then of
course like on top of the operating
system then you have different like open
source project like the apache web
server and and so forth that somehow you
try to kind of run on on top of this
whole thing
so one one thing that's very clear like
looking at this slide is that it
required a lot of technical knowledge
like back in the day to put together
even the most basic website and like you
probably need to have a team of maybe a
sys admin and a database admin and then
like maybe a php developer to be able to
put even the kind of the most
rudimentary site together not to talk
about the payment processing and stuff
like that that might actually matter for
e-commerce
so like obviously like what happened
after a while i mean actually a long
while 15 years is that there was this
next generation of the stack for web
development it was called the mean stack
like from the hmong odp as the database
express js as the as the as the web
server and uh and angular maybe as the
front end framework and then node.js is
kind of the language runtime
and like one thing that's especially
interesting to me here is that if you
compare and contrast if you maybe
remember uh like when mongodb came out
there was actually like a lot of debate
in technical circles whether with a
mongodb is actually a good product in
the first place because there was there
were many technical arguments that in
many ways mongodb wasn't the technical
technically a better product and let's
say my sequel that people had been using
using before but at the same time
mongodb was resonating like with a huge
number of web developers people building
these applications mainly for the reason
that they kind of changed the
abstraction a bit i mean one thing was
that they introduced this idea of a
document-based database so instead of
having relations and sql and all that
fancy relational ultra stuff that that
had been dominating the database
industry for decades they had this very
ideal simple idea that you have a json
object and then you can just operate
with the json object and everything
everything will be fine and now of
course like many technical people felt
that oh that's that's horrible but at
the same time i mean the the level of
abstraction like raised to the point
that people who hadn't been able to
build these database applications in the
past suddenly were able to do it
and the same thing with many other
components here i mean like express js
like higher level than apache of course
like you can see that the operating
system at this point actually like it
drops from the picture like kind of it
was given i mean like linux was already
at the point in time that like well
things just mainly worked so you
wouldn't have to worry about all those
device drivers and whatnot and also like
the language like well i mean one can
argue with it whether like javascript is
higher level than php but like things
get kept evolving there as well
and now like if you think like what's
kind of the the state of the art today
like there's this little thing called
the jam stack already introduced 2015
but i think it's only now gaining
popularity where the idea is that like
the stack is even simpler so now i mean
you're still using javascript but like
today like if you are building let's say
an e-commerce store like you don't much
have to even like think about databases
definitely not operating systems not
load balancers and so forth but maybe
you use a platform like like shopify or
like maybe you use some super high level
framework maybe you deploy a single page
application on versailles i mean just
talking to the apis and much of that
technical complexity underneath is
totally hidden from you
so the overall like a trend line like in
all these technical stacks is that
things tend to become more human-centric
and less technical over time and like
when i say human-centric i mean the idea
that if you think that like in order to
build an application you kind of have to
the lower layers you have to all the way
to the hardware and the cpus and then
like at the top of the thing i mean you
have you have the thing that actually
like interfaces with other human beings
maybe it is the actual store now we have
so much more mental bandwidth to focus
on on like how do we make the onboarding
how do we make the signup flow how do we
make the purchase experience better and
like we don't have to consider the
technical details and that's how things
tend to happen over over time like with
these technical stacks
and now like maybe something that's even
more exciting is that
yep that these stacks definitely become
simpler but not only simpler but also
more capable over time and i guess like
the point about simplicity uh is
important like especially if you
contrast that to the idea that the kind
of simplicity implies that things used
to be more complex in the past and then
they become simpler there's also this
kind of somehow there's maybe the
intuition that somehow like as things
become more advanced they become more
complex but it's actually fascinating to
think that oftentimes it works other way
around that we start with something
that's overly complex and has a lot of
this incidental accidental complexity
because kind of in the early days of
these industries we simply don't know
what we should be doing actually it's
it's kind of rational that like in the
early days like we we explore many
different directions we try out all
kinds of things provide technical
affordances and over time only over time
we learn like what actually makes sense
what is important for the people who
build these applications and then over
time we can shed all this unnecessary
complexity from the stack and things
become simpler and at the same time like
we can focus our energies and like then
like providing all these capabilities
like more easy payment processing with
stripe or or like whatever it might be
so it's kind of like oftentimes in
engineering we have trade-offs that like
we can't get everything but i mean like
in the case of stacks i mean it seems
that like we got both get things that
are simpler as well as more capable
so that's kind of like a like the
mindset the way how i have been thinking
about the stack and like since the title
of this talk is the the modern stack for
for ml infrastructure i have all reasons
to believe that the ml industry is no
different because it's not only the web
stacks but it's also the mobile it's
it's whatever else you're looking at i
mean this seems to be the almost like a
physical law law of physics that like
this is this is how these things tend to
go so there's a reason to believe that
like when it comes to building a
real-world ml applications things will
become simpler and more capable and more
human-centric also over time
so now like what it means in practice is
that um
if if you um i go back in time like when
i think like the first ml applications
that i built a long time ago like it was
kind of a maybe using this like a clam
stuck don't google clam i mean just came
up with the name but um
the pretty much the idea was back in
like early 2000s or maybe even like
before the 2000s that maybe you were in
academia building something the only way
how you could actually like say it like
a build like a train a model is that
first i mean there were very few
off-the-shelf frameworks available so
most likely you hacked the algorithm by
hand
most definitely using some low-level
language um unless you were using matlab
like as an id which was kind of
interesting that in many ways it was
kind of ahead of its time um but um like
you would use c and then like you would
also of course like a very tightly like
of work with the operating system
because like the operating systems
tended to be a bit if it's still a kind
of a like a flakier buffer at the time
especially when it when you wanted to do
numerical high performance numerical
computing and then like well i mean
because so much time was spent on just
building the algorithms i mean not much
time was spent on all the data stuff so
maybe you just use something like perl
or awk to do the data processing like
just like get the columns from the csv
that you needed so that was really quite
rudimentary back then and now if you
fast forward 20 years and 20 years kind
of a long time and now like back in 2018
i mean of course there's like things
have advanced massively i mean if you
one of of course the biggest difference
is that um instead of tracking and
stacking physical servers like we can
just rely on the cloud which
like frees up massive amount of energy
and like kind of a mental bandwidth to
focus on other things so instead of
setting up linux servers you can just
use use aws
and of course well this conference is
all about data so i don't even have to
say like how much have changed like when
it comes to data processing the data
warehouses orchestration system etl all
that stuff and and like what is maybe
even more exciting like in the ml point
of view is that instead of you having to
implement all these algorithms by hand
in c they are these amazingly uh mature
uh ml frameworks like of course
tensorflow or pytorch or xgboost
scikit-learn like whatever what what
have you and then you can use a
high-level language high-level language
like python do to kind of get your job
done and then like you can put things
together like using jupiter and and so
forth so a huge huge amount of progress
over the next over the past 20 years or
so
but of course the interesting question
remains that um well today is 2022
and in a few years it will be 2025 and
so forth and like most likely the stack
will keep evolving and like if we kind
of like follow this linear path about
things becoming more human-centric and
like even even like more capable over
time simpler the interesting question is
that okay what's going to happen like
what will the future look like
and um now predicting predicting future
is hard actually predicting past is even
hard like prediction is hard but um
one of the one of the best ways to kind
of uh predict the future is to create it
i guess like it was ellen k who said
that so now for this talk i thought that
like we can go through this interesting
thought exercise that if you were to
design an ml infrastructure stack from
scratch today how would you do it like
what are what are like those pieces that
you think will inevitably be around over
the next let's say five to ten years so
if if we believe in this idea that like
in the early days of any industry like
we we have a lot of this incidental
complexity because we don't know like
what we are doing
at this point maybe we have some idea of
the essentials like what are those
essential components that we know that
we can't get rid of and like we want to
we want to have as a part of our stack
and now like the first thing that i
believe in and actually like i'd be
curious to hear if there's anybody in
the audience who doesn't believe in this
i do believe that there will be people
around and not hopefully i mean this is
not like a climate change or anything
that like the people would go extinct
but specifically there will be data
scientists around and actually like this
is not just a joke because there is a
there is a kind of a question that if
let's say the auto ml takes over the
world and like we just the data goes to
some some system that automatically
optimizes everything i mean yes i mean
there's a possible world like where even
this guy like won't be won't be around
in 10 years
but i mean let's let's start with with
the premise that like we will have data
scientists
and um if you take any any
random data scientist today you look at
the person like during the business
hours most likely you will find them on
a laptop
and uh well now i mean starting with the
very basics the question is that okay so
uh is this going to be the situation in
10 years well now there is the very like
a physical interface that most likely
like they will be still typing something
i mean most likely i would even argue
that they might be typing code they
might be typing high level code again i
mean this is a big belief there are like
definitely people who much believe in
the no code or even maybe some kind of a
low code but but let's say that like
especially like python languages it's an
exceptionally good way for people to
express their understanding of the world
in a computable form and i think that
that will be around
but now the interesting question is that
okay so they are typing something on the
laptop but what what happens then like
what happens with that code
and now like for the past 40 years like
we have had had this concept of a
personal computer and the personal
computer is of course quite a
revolutionary idea because it meant that
you get this personal sandbox where you
can experiment with things you can
install things and you can run things
and and like nobody kind of interferes
with your stuff randomly and like in
many ways it is quite empowering and
productivity boosting at the same time
there are like some quite big
limitations with that personal computer
idea like one of them of course being
that they tend to be on the smaller side
uh and also like as
like ml becomes more and more serious of
course i guess many companies have have
seen over the past many many decades is
that managing personal computers is kind
of a bit of a pain in the butt and like
it like in the in the data governance in
the security point of view like moving
things in in a more easily controllable
environment like like the cloud actually
makes makes life easier
and and now when it comes to ml like
besides those like a governance question
there is also the very practical
question
that because we want to make it very
easy to move stuff from prototype to
production it's important that like we
minimize any kind of a gap between the
prototype and production and now if you
consider that your laptop as of today is
maybe a macbook with the m1 rm processor
and like your production workloads might
be x86 running in the cloud we know that
there are quite concrete differences
between the packages you install on your
local laptop and the packages you might
be using in production and this is
actually like quite specific to ml
because if you are using only high-level
languages like javascript you wouldn't
have this problem but in ml i mean this
is this is a real deal and in that sense
also it is beneficial that like you kind
of remove the actual workloads that you
are executing even during prototyping to
the cloud so there is the idea of a
cloud workstation and i think that
that's a that's a positive direction
there's of course much work to be done
but like even today you can use vs code
you can use jupyter and it's quite a
seamless experience even if you run
those kernels on a remote instance
now the next piece that i think that we
won't be able to get rid of like for the
benefit of this conference is that i
think we will always have data and now
there's of course a whole separate track
about about the the modern data stack
and like where the where the data
engineering side of the house is going
but um let's let's just assume like for
for the purposes of this presentation
that we have some kind of a data
warehouse data lake someplace where you
have where all the business has has like
the data so you have the master data
record maybe it's data break snowflake
maybe whatever it is
and then the important realization here
is that um
we don't want the ml to be an island we
don't want ml to be a separate world
card and that like you have your rest of
the business living in some other data
warehouse and then you have your data
scientists working in some separate
environment and maybe you can get fine
symbols of data in that specific
environment but more and more it would
be beneficial that like everybody like
has the same view to the data everybody
agrees on the definitions of the metrics
everybody agrees on the on the on the
kind of tables and of course like we
want to enable like people to iterate on
quickly but at least we are kind of
living in the same universe of data and
also it means that the data scientist is
more freely able to access access like
the kind of the actual data sets not
only tiny samples of data
and now like with this
like comes the big question like the
other like a really foundational
question is that how do we do compute
and actually like if you just look at
this picture here that's kind of the
holy trinity of what all ml what all ml
infrastructure is about i mean it's some
kind of a
conglomeration of of people data and
compute so i mean like everything we do
is kind of somewhere in this triangle of
compute data and people
um and like now the compute it's
actually like a surprisingly
multi-dimensional question i mean one
one of the most obvious ways of thinking
about this like a computer system well
it allows us to use to provide
scalability and now as many of you know
like there are two ways to scale you can
either scale vertically meaning that you
can get bigger and bigger boxes so let's
say you're you need to load a pandas
data frame in memory it takes 200
gigabytes of ram you can actually like
get an instance with 200 gigabytes or
like 300 gigabytes of ram from the cloud
and instead of like spending time on
optimizing things by hand you can just
get the bigger instance and actually
like that can be very productivity
boosting
now
of course you can't infinitely scale
that way i mean at some point you hit
the limits the limits are surprisingly
high like today so that shouldn't be
underestimated but like at some point
you hit the limit so then like the other
direction is that you have the
horizontal scalability which is the idea
that you can get more of these boxes
and now the beautiful idea with the
cloud is that it really affords both
types of scalability you can either get
bigger boxes or you can get more boxes
and or like some combination of the two
now like besides the scalability
question the compute is important
because it actually like does even like
a change the way how we think about the
organization
how we think about how people interact
with each other because if you think
like what used to be the situation like
maybe like a long time ago uh like maybe
with the mainframe
there were only a few people who were
even able to go near the computer
because it was such a limited constraint
resource
and then at some point we got personal
computers so we could democratize the
access to compute and then maybe at some
point like in late 1990s early 2000s
maybe your company had like a few racks
of servers cluster running there
and uh and and like then maybe you had
some kind of a sophisticated shop
queuing system prioritization that like
who gets to run like what and when and
the challenge with that idea is that
like usually when it comes to
experimentation which is super important
for for data science usually the
experimental workloads are never like
getting a very high priority and like
now you have to kind of carefully dance
around it like who gets to run and what
then when
and i think that that's a bit of a thing
that like we can we can kind of start
changing our mindset about like with the
cloud then well technically if you
assume this idea that cloud provides
nearly virtually unlimited scalability
there's no reason why we need to kind of
have these like like a checks and
gatekeepers like who gets to run stuff i
mean technically like we should be able
to allow anybody to access these
resources very freely
and of course this would be amazing for
experimentation because now suddenly in
this post scarcity world like we can
actually like try out all kinds of
things we can try like a different
ensembles of models run them in parallel
and so forth and usually the pushback
that i get from from companies like when
saying this is of course it costs money
and like well maybe netflix can afford
doing it but i mean like our company
can't and yeah that's that's that's
there it costs money and of course the
challenge here is that um that that
there's the cost side of the the
business and then there's the value side
and now the kind of the simple thinking
goes that like well if you understand
the value of what you are creating as
long as the value of this
experimentation is higher than the cost
i mean then it's a no-brainer you should
still do it now the challenge is that
most companies don't understand the
value of experimentation it's hard to
measure anyways but the point being that
technically the mechanism of letting
people access the cloud is at least
something that we can enable and then
like based on your understanding of the
how the value gets created you can layer
policies on like who
how we kind of allocate the money
between teams and there's a difference
between the mechanism and the policy and
that's that's that's important to keep
in mind
now
in many ways this is this is kind of
like a very positive story of liberation
that like we are liberating the data
scientists from the confines of the
laptop we are liberating them from
having to deal with small data sets
liberating them like from not being able
to use compute resources and there's
actually like one more like a point of
liberation that i feel is really
important which is that it's a
liberation like from the previous shop
description so it used to be so that
like maybe you had analysts providing
insights for the company maybe you had
data scientists producing models and
maybe then like ml engineer building
applications and and like you had
division of work like that
but now if you draw the comparison like
from the the kind of the web stack world
what happened over over like the past
whatever like 20 years like in the web
stack is that you used to have teams of
sys admins dpas php developers building
these applications and over time we have
got to the point that is only the full
stack developer taking care of
everything as a single full stack
developer today you can build end-to-end
applications and it's not because the
full stack developers are necessarily
like some kind of a magical unicorns
knowing everything including the linux
device drivers today but it says that
the level of abstraction is is higher
and also the kind of the the the kind of
the way how we build software is is a
bit different like we are focusing our
energies on different points
and like on that note i i do think that
this idea of of workflows which is of
course like not i don't think that it's
maybe not new to anyone here so i mean
like of course most likely everybody
doing data engineering or or like kind
of a data science knows this idea that
you can structure things as a workflow
but the interesting thing as of today is
that still many companies if not most
companies consider that the workflow is
something that you kind of slap on top
of everything afterwards
after like the data scientist has done
their work so oftentimes what happens is
that still as of today the data
scientists let's say prototype something
in a notebook or like writes a python
file and then like afterwards like
somebody slaps a yama on top of that
like stitching together these individual
components and it goes through a ci cd
system and then it gets executed and
what it means is that it becomes of
course incredibly painful to quickly
iterate like on the on the workflow on
the kind of this application itself
because it's somehow external to the
whole thing and it kind of feels that
the healthier idea would be to consider
that workflow as the kind of the main
deliverable of what the data scientist
is working on which also means that it
needs to be an integral part of that
local prototyping loop
and now like with this with this like i
create the amount of freedom that like
we would like to grant to all the data
scientists machine learning engineers of
course comes a certain degree of
responsibility
and uh and like
the responsibility these days like
should come in the form of of tracking
like we want to understand the metadata
we want to understand the different
versions that get built and now as we
very well know i mean when it comes to
machine learning it's not only about the
version of the code it's also the
versioning the data understanding the
lineage of data understanding the the
models that get built
and now i would claim that this part is
so integral to everything what we do
especially as we start empowering these
data scientists to do more by themselves
is that it needs to be an absolute like
a built in component of the whole system
and not a yet another add-on component
that like somehow you have to do as as
an after do it like after that like once
you have done everything else
so it kind of becomes i think um
peter like mentioned something in the in
the keynote this morning about this idea
of how when you adapt the kind of the
culture of experimentation when you
adopted experimentation mindset like you
also have to be very conscious about the
change management and like understanding
how things change and i think that that
that idea that idea of like a tracking
like what gets built is is very central
to this and of course like many software
engineers know the idea of a git ops
which is the way how we do it in the
software engineering lab today i think
that we can do even better in the world
of data science
but the end result is that when we put
all these things together like we get
this kind of a modern prototyping loop
and the modern prototyping loop doesn't
only include the data scientists on
their laptop but it also includes access
to the data it includes access to the to
the compute resources quite freely it
includes the workflow part as well and
of course like even during the
prototyping we want to keep track of
everything and understand what's going
on
and now like since uh all this is all
this is like pretty high level and
abstract i mean we can make it a bit
more concrete by by like saying a few
for it's about metaflow so now like
miraflow ever since the beginning was
kind of built with this mindset with
this vision that this is maybe where the
world is going now by no means i'm
claiming that this is the only way
they're all the only implementation only
possible way so of course there are many
other frameworks and like many many
other implementations that will
show up over time but i mean just to
make it concrete let me show how we have
been doing it
so
for those of you who haven't seen maybe
metaflow before it's a very very kind of
a simple python framework by design we
want to get rid of all that incidental
complexity
and like it promotes this idea of a
workflow to be a first-class concept i
mean it's not models that data science
they start building but they're building
data science applications of different
forms and and like they are being
structured structured as a workflow so
you have a workflow here you have like
let's say we have two nodes here start
and end
and and like correspondingly we have two
methods in the python code start and end
they are decorated with the ad steps so
we know that those are the nodes in the
graph and then there's the edge between
the start and end which is the self.next
transition in the code so so very very
straightforward nothing too special
about this well now like what is what is
really nice is that
if you want to test your code i mean
let's say you didn't have the workflow
you were just operating in a jupyter
notebook of course like you would like
to run the code in the jupyter notebook
now that you have the workflow in the
same way you want to run it locally and
see if it works so in the case of
metaflow like it gives you this like a
very simple command line interface you
can just say python my flow run and it
executes the workflow locally in the
same way as you would do it in the
notebook so you don't have to deploy it
anywhere you don't have to write any any
separate dml files and all that stuff
you just test the workflow as the main
main deliverable of your project
so now the next question is that okay
about the compute so the compute indeed
i mean it should be a core core part of
this exercise so now
as i mentioned there are two kinds of um
scalability and like and we just
demonstrate them here so first is the
horizontal scalability so let's say you
want to train 200 models
uh 200 models maybe like kind of a one
one model for every country in the world
or something like that what you can do
do
is that you can define a python list
like here like a self params and you can
do that okay i want to do for each over
the params and then like what metaflo
does behind the scenes is that it farms
out 200 copies of this task to the
compute platform of your choice
and now when it comes to vertical
scalability we have the ad resources so
you can say that okay i want maybe i'm
loading a big data frame maybe i'm like
training a big model or something so i
need like at least 100 gigs of ram so i
can see that say that okay like i need
128 gigs of ram like for each one of
these boxes
and this is all that the data scientist
has to do to be able to inform the
system that okay i want to do many
things in parallel and like i need i
need big boxes and then you can just
like run the code again locally i mean
you don't have to do anything more than
that like and you can say that okay if
you know that your engineers are using
kubernetes and like you have set up
kubernetes as the compute layer you can
say run with kubernetes and then like
the behind the scenes like we package
everything and like submit to the
cluster and like all that stuff that
needs to happen kubernetes is not the
only choice you can use aws patch or
like maybe in the future like other
compute layers but the key idea here is
that like in the data scientist point of
view i mean it's it's really pretty
seamless i mean in some sense i mean
like if i'm building this code i kind of
don't care at all like how these
functions get executed i just want them
to be executed somehow and and like of
course there are actually a lot of
engineering complexity in executing
functions at scale and so forth that
shouldn't be underestimated but when i
mean that like a data science mindset i
don't have to worry about that
so
then like the other idea is this
question of like tracking everything by
default so like now when you execute
code in metaflow when you do it whenever
you do self.x like you assign something
due to variables those things get
persisted automatically so you can
actually go back in time and ask
questions about the workflow that what
was the state of the what was the date
after executing this step or like what
was the data that was input to my model
or you can like to see um like kind of
the the compare experiments over
experiments and all that stuff and the
key part is that it's not an add-on i
mean it happens automatically you don't
even have to write extra lines of code
to make it happen
and i'm actually like in the interest of
time i i don't want to spend too much
time on this question like how to
interface with data warehouses although
it's definitely a really an interesting
one but stuff is to say that the modern
data warehouses like snowflakes and
later prxes and like whatnot they have
the capability of creating creating
materialized views that like you can
create and then like you can download
really fast let's say from s3 allowing
you to kind of create these massive
ensembles of models really fast without
having the the data warehouse becoming
the bottleneck or like the data
scientist taking down the whole
warehouse or anything of that sort so
come and talk to me afterwards if you're
interested
so um so i think like we have time like
for this like a tiny demo at least for
those of you who haven't um seen uh like
medaflow the latest things that we have
done so i think this might be fun
so
so what this shows is first like we have
a ui
that was released just a few months ago
so where you can see what's what's going
on like it's just like a basic meta flow
code i know this is way too fast so
don't worry about details but the idea
is that you can test it locally you can
just like run it as i showed you and now
the whole workflow runs locally the nice
thing is that like if you have this ui
installed you can just like go to the ui
see what's going on like how long the
different tasks are taking and so forth
and a nifty new feature is that now i
mean with a few lines of python code you
can also like create these outputs that
are understandable to humans so of
course like the main idea like with
these workflows is that we are building
models we are processing data all that
stuff but it is actually tremendously
useful that like you can get these like
a tiny reports that are attached to the
execution that you can then see that
okay what's going on in my in my models
like built in and of course there are
many many many like reporting solutions
the model monitoring solution and so
forth but one of the key problem with
many of them is that you have to
actually do quite a bit of work in
attaching them to do all the executions
both during prototype and production and
then like thanks to all the versioning
that metaflo does behind the scenes you
can just take any version id and let's
say afterwards go to a notebook and ask
that oh by the way i mean that model
seemed to be performing real well or not
and you can just like see the report
card in a notebook
so all these features the kind of the ui
and and the cards they were something
that was just like released um
like like towards the end of last year
so so even if you have seen metaflow in
the past these are new features that
might be interesting to you as well
so now
just kind of this is big question that
like needs to be addressed that okay so
now we have this amazing prototyping
loop so how do we think about the
production
well i mean like what we have learned
about production over the past many many
years like when it comes to machine
learning is there isn't a one type of
production but machine learning is kind
of becoming like software engineering in
the sense that it comes in all shapes
and sizes and like as you know you can
apply machine learning on the edge you
can have computer vision on the mobile
devices you can have a recommendations
on a web product like netflix or maybe
you use a data enrichment you add
predictions to your data stream so maybe
you have some decision support system
and all these are of course production
use cases
and i i think that the most concise
definition that we have for production
is just like a two attributes what makes
production the attribute number one is
that it should work without human
supervision so the idea that like if you
somehow have to run something manually
all the time it kind of doesn't quite
feel production so at least it's
unsupervised it's automated that's an
important part of production and then
the second one is that there's a bit of
an like assumption that things don't
break all the time so it needs to be
highly available so production means
that you are automated and you are
highly available
now you can be highly available and
automated in many different contexts all
these cases are production
um
and and with this like comes the idea
that there isn't like a single way how
how the data scientist deploys machine
learning production but in fact there
are many different ways and we of course
don't want to burden the data scientists
and having to think about like every
every every build the kind of every
deployment pattern from scratch which is
why we can have these like blueprints
for different targets but what this
allows us to do is that it also means
that
it's so important that like we can
integrate to the surrounding production
infrastructure for each use case
separately there isn't like a
one-size-fits-all way of doing
production like what works for like
netflix scale recommendations is very
different than like what works for the
decision support system at the bank or
like the edge devices and so forth each
one of these cases is different but the
key part here is that the prototyping
loop in the middle can be quite the same
for all of these cases because these
things compute data versioning
orchestration they're quite universal
and then like once you are like happy
with your result you can apply like one
of these patterns to kind of a deploy
deploy stuff to production
and just as a concrete example uh what
it can mean is that let's say um your
company uses one of the uh like
production like workflow orchestration
engines let's say airflow or amazon step
function so argo in production now a key
part is that it is highly beneficial
that your machine learning workflows run
with the same system in the same
environment as all the other data
pipelines and the idea that like somehow
you have a separate world for data and
like separate world for ml and like
separate for like production system it
actually like it's a sign of incidental
complexity which is exactly the thing
that we want to get rid of so in the
case of metaflow we have these adapters
so you can deploy let's say you can do
step functions create you can deploy to
step functions or actually like argo and
airflow are features that are coming
later this spring
and
now equally important part here is that
this is not the one-way street it's not
not something that you you you deploy as
a kind of a waterfall but when things
fail in production like you need to be
able to come back and then reproduce
those issues and fix them and then like
deploy the fixed version back and this
is actually something that's
surprisingly often missing in our
production systems that we know let's
say with ci cd how we deploy the
production but no one ever thinks how we
come back from production meaning that
then like in the production we slap all
kind of observability tools and we slap
all kinds of alerting tools that if
something goes wrong at least we know
but oftentimes then after thought to
think that okay so how do we actually
fix these problems as quickly as
possible because the definition of high
availability is not only that things
never fail it also means that when
things fail as they inevitably fail how
can you fix things as quickly as
possible and that's why for instance
like we have this receiving feature like
how you can resume even any production
execution locally in an isolated
environment doesn't step on the toes of
anything in production and fix those
issues and then then go back
then
another like important aspect of
production is that it never ends like
it's kind of fascinating fact about
about of course like all software but i
mean machine learning and particle that
like if you manage to build something
that creates value nobody ever wants to
take that down it becomes this eternal
like organism that never dies like you
only want to improve it and like so you
kind of get into this like a cycle that
you have both the prototyping loop and
then you have this like a constant
iteration on the on the production
things and oftentimes um like the way
how you want to improve this like the
production systems is that let's say you
you create somebody creates a new
version and then you deploy it but you
just don't overwrite the main production
version but you deployed side by side
with the production and then maybe you
conduct some kind of an ab experiment
and you want to test like whether the
new thing is better than the old thing
because as many of you who do ml very
well know i mean it's really hard to say
in advance if model a is better than
model b without actually like seeing how
they behave in practice and i think also
this is this is very much the reality
like where we are already living today
and increasing we'll be living in the
future that in contrast to software
engineering like where we can at least
test things and get some idea if it
works or not like as a binary thing
increasingly like we can't know if these
systems work without deploying them all
the way to production but not overriding
things dumbly but i mean just running
things side by side
and in order to be able to do this i
mean of course the whole setup needs to
support this idea of having these
isolated whole like sequences of
workflows that can run side by side and
again i mean like so many so many
companies that i see today and i talked
to today i mean they are like at the
point where they can barely deploy one
thing and then when i ask them that okay
i mean what if somebody else wants to
test the new version and like run it
side by side just shaking their head and
like that no i mean like we wouldn't
ever dare to do anything like that which
is which is kind of sad because that's
how you actually start constantly
improving things
and then like finally like kind of after
after like we are done with all this
like we get to the parts that are
somehow feel that are very very much to
the core of data science i mean this is
the part like where the data scientists
and this is kind of the part like why we
need a data scientist in the loop
because this is how you actually map
your domain knowledge about the world
like to the system so there's of course
the whole thread like the movement about
data centric ai which means that okay
when it comes to let's say feature
engineering which again like comes in
many shapes and sizes how you do feature
engineering for computer vision is very
different how you do it for relational
data which is very different how you do
it for streaming data or semi-structured
data but this is the place where you
actually map your domain knowledge like
to the system many many ways how you can
do that and then finally you slap the
model on top of on top of the kind of
the creative datasets and the features
and again i mean depending on the use
case you can you can use all kinds of
frameworks and of course i mean this is
a fast moving field the key idea like
with this with this whole modern ml
infrastructure stack is that we can
allow data scientists to have almost a
maximal amount of freedom at the top of
the stack like we want them to map their
domain knowledge in the form of models
we want them to map their domain
knowledge in the form of features but
then like when you have these like a
foundational features like like how you
access data from the data warehouse
compute orchestration versioning it's
something that the the the framework
that the platform can take care of you
and like those are kind of a
non-negotiable so you have to have
versioning you have to have compute you
have to have data but then like how you
like implement these things much more
freedom at the top of the chart
and then like also we believe that like
the key idea like how you build how
anybody should be thinking about these
modern stacks whether it's machine
learning or like web stack is that you
want to provide a coherent experience so
that you get rid of that incidental
complexity the incidental complexity
let's say in the early web stacks came
from the fact that you had a separate
operating system and you had a separate
database and you had a separate like
language and then so forth and like none
of these things actually like work
seamlessly together and like you were
constantly fighting at the seams of the
systems and the same thing of course
like happens today with the ml
infrastructure you have different parts
and they don't quite fit together and
it's complicated and and like these
things are like flaky
and like building these coherent ideas
is of course like not easy and you don't
want to reinvent everything that you
don't want to reinvent every wheel in
the world like you can integrate with
the existing systems but at least at the
user interface layer like you want to
have a coherent user experience
so this is my belief like where the
world will be going again i mean like
definitely there will be many
implementations on the right hand side i
mean
hopefully of course like one of them
will be metaflow but um but i mean
definitely if you are building like
internal frameworks or like if you are
building commercial products i mean
definitely like i try to project based
on like everything we have seen in the
past where things are going
and like tests is like a shameless plug
i've been
writing about this stuff in a book
because i always run out of time and uh
so you can go and buy the book so the
profits like from the book go to go to
good quality so like even even if the
book is worthless at least the money
goes for it of course
and also we have a slack as everybody
else so so please join thank you